bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors on le sentait venir depuis
quelques mois c'est désormais presque
officiel à tik tok va disparaître aux
etats unis comment l'interpréter moi moi
je serai peut-être moins catégorique sur
le fait que la disparition en tant que
tel à il est tout à fait possible que
cette annonce à soi qu'il annonce
typiques de là de la manière dont
monsieur trump négociait déjà dans le
domaine des affaires à négocier encore
aujourd'hui qu'il était à la tête de
l'état américain
c'est à dire simplement un moyen de
pression pour obtenir ce qui serait dans
mon estime on hypothèses et valide son
véritable objectif c'est-à-dire le fait
que la maison mère chinoise de tik tok
bon entreprises tic tac à d'autres
actionnaires qui quand elles seraient
totalement distinct je dirai au taux
légal chinois est ce qu'on peut
considérer ça comme un nouvel affront à
la chine dans cette guerre commerciale
qui n'en finit plus économiquement pékin
va-t-il perdre gros avec la perte de la
clientèle américaine en tout cas tik tok
va-t-il perdre gros avec la perte de
cette clientèle c'est à dire que oui tik
tok étant économiquement non pas
juridiquement mais économiquement
parlant une entreprise d'abord
américaine c'est une interdiction qui
signerait sinon la raide mort en tout
cas la mort cérébrale de l'entreprise
citées par contre je crois que c'est une
erreur d'analysé total que 10 voix un
aléas de la guerre commerciale il s'agit
ici d'une guerre géopolitique d'une
guerre entre deux modèles culturels ont
feint d'oublier dans la plus grande
partie de l'occident que les cas chinois
et le parti communiste chinois
c'est à dire le continuateur d'un régime
qui a commis à des génocides et
massacrent absolument abominable au 20e
siècle
le parti communiste chinois est
responsable de la mort de millions de
ses concitoyens aujourd'hui à il y a
plus vraiment l'équivalent ça encore que
les musulmans chinois souffrent des
choses qui seraient totalement
inacceptable dans le monde occidental
mais il ya en revanche une stratégie de
domination mondiale qui a été mise au
point par la chine et je crois que c'est
beaucoup plus dans ce cadre là qu'il
faut analyser ce type d'action au jeu
des roues de réaction du gouvernement
américain que dans le cadre
de la guerre commerciale qui me paraît
en l'occurrence ici totalement étranger
au sujet techtoc se défend en affirmant
qu en rien cette application est
politique comment la chine va réagir
selon vous le l'autre erreur d analyse
de la plupart des commentateurs
européens notamment et de ne pas voir
que la chine est économiquement aux
abois et se trouve aujourd'hui dans une
phase de reprise en main politique qui
est la traduction de cette très grande
faiblesse je dirais économique alors la
chine
il est impossible pour moi de dire de
quelle façon elle réagirait si cette
interdiction à devenait effective mais
je ne suis pas certain réellement ans
qu'elle aurait les moyens politiques
économiques ou même militaire de réagir
de manière trop agressive jeudi vol à
l'égard du régime américain ou de ces
entreprises
d'autres pays ont déjà franchi par tels
que l'inde la france également à soins
des interrogations autour de la
plateforme hormis les accusations
d'espionnage de donald trump quels sont
les reproches qui sont faits à cette
application c'est à dire que ce que nos
auditeurs doivent bien comprendre c'est
que lorsque l'on parle d'une entreprise
chinoise
on parle de l'état chinois c'est à dire
du parti communiste chinois
donc dire que tik tok secrète une
entreprise chinoise un peu comme google
est une entreprise américaine est
évidemment une erreur d'analysé et de
perspectives complet google est une
entreprise juridiquement économiquement
et dans les faits séparez distingue
d'ailleurs elle se pose souvent du
gouvernement américain ce n'est vrai
d'aucune entreprise chinoise qui dans le
système essentiellement autorités avoir
totalité chinois n'a pas les moyens de
se poser je dirais à l'état chinois
alors le fait que le gouvernement
chinois met à profit un certain nombre
de seize entreprises se sont toujours en
dernière analyse ces entreprises pour se
livrer notamment à de l'espionnage mais
sur des proportions parfaitement
industriels à l'égard de l'occident et
notamment en termes de avec des visées
de deux vols de secrets commerciaux etc
c'est une réalité qui est factuelle qui
n'est pas contestable
merci beaucoup de votre crédit d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes docteur en philosophie